[Music]
okay good so welcome to this talk and
it's about advance user experience with
tensorflow J's and I'm Oliver and this
talk really is it is about user
experience but it's much more about
finding good applications for machine
learning in the browser and I want to
kick this off because I have zero slides
so I want to kick this off with a stone
joke hopefully no one knows it already
so this is about user experience and oh
sorry this is about user experience in
the way it actually works so hope for
the internet works here so this is what
you the user do so it doesn't work quite
obviously guys wrong fixing it this is I
mean because you're laughing I know you
have the same feeling as me yeah if you
have watch people using user so same
thing fixing it again yes so that's the
joke that I stole but obviously it
worked
because I think it only works if you
have some sort of experience like this
you think so hard about you user
interface and then that's what people
end up doing they will figure out how to
how to deal with it but maybe not them
sense you expected it so this talk is
about the same thing don't blame me for
the for the styling this is my weak spot
oh wait so um in a typical user
interface so this regard those buttons
those are real buttons the the buttons
down here I'm not real buttons so the
buttons are just here to make a point so
typically in a very classic user
interface the buttons they will light up
when you hover over them to give people
the the certainty when you click now you
will click this button so what I had in
mind was would it be at all possible to
highlight the buttons before you click
them so would it be possible that the
machine learns
which button are you going to click now
on next and
you may ask what could be the
applications of this and I've talked to
quite some user experience people that
said nothing or less and then they
thought for a little bit longer so maybe
I asked you so I get something back here
why would even do that I mean highlight
the button before the user clicks on it
predicting which button is it going to
be any ideas any takers yes perfect so
about flows so actually I haven't
implemented this but with the buttons up
there that's a horrible user interface
because you need to click those buttons
in certain order and some orders are
totally don't make any sense you get
weird error messages this would be my
next step like learn how to actually use
those buttons up there because they're
they're complex but I haven't
implemented this yet so what what would
be another reason why would you why
would you do that yes accessibility yes
so make it easier so that was also my
fault yes you have another point yes in
the back sorry yes
preload resources that was also
something that I came up with someone
said maybe there so I don't know a
server less function behind that button
and you want to start it up because you
think oh the user is going to click on
that button soon you better have this
thing ready or preload the next page or
someone I've written down some stuff
wait oh yeah someone came up with the
idea when there's artificial reality and
it's always pretty hard to decide which
detail are you going to show and then if
you can predict where the user is going
to look next then you can preload that
stuff and again I only implemented the
easiest word because I just wanted to
know it's this at all possible could you
even do that
and the easiest version that I
implemented is just what you said I
highlighted the button that I think the
users going to click so um there could
be heuristics to do this you could just
measure I don't know it's the user close
to a button like this and if the if it's
reasonably close then you would
highlight that button which I don't do
now and you could also check its the
mouse closer to this button and so they
and it might all work but it might not
match the individual style that someone
has that used this user interface for
example my I always use the trackpad and
it's extremely sensitive because I don't
move much and that might mean if I want
to hit this button
I might briefly go over it and then go
back that means depending on the user
that you're having and depending on the
machine that you're using and how is it
set up the mouse movements might be
completely different so I'm pretty sure
in my I'm not sure that I'm pretty sure
a machine might identify me just by my
mouse movements out of all of the people
in the on somebody's nodding I haven't
made the experience but my mouse mouse
movements are so weird Italy makes
people really nervous angry so having
said that so what I came up with is that
I said maybe it's possible to learn that
those movements using machine gun and if
you want to do that the the crucial part
is you need data
so the typical machine learning that we
do you need to have data and if you
don't have data probably not going to
work but fortunately I can generate data
on the fly and I'm doing it like this so
once I hover over button I generate a
data set and typically the user would
also need to click that button but it
would take me forever to generate just a
few data samples if I really clicked on
that button so for the sake of this demo
I'm just counting hovering over button
is a click this is this is just fake or
hacked but that's the only hack part and
I'm doing this to quickly get some data
yeah and what kind of data would you I
mean I'm generating data what kind of
data would you would you collect what
would you do I mean if you were to
predict the button I'm going to click
you solve those movements what would you
recall yes
proximity you could record that I did
not do this what else yes yes that's
what I did so I recorded XY of the mouse
I recorded the Delta between the
previous
movement because I just get this from
the mouse movie event I just get this
for free and delta-t exactly what you
say
so and there's also something really
special about this I recalled a sequence
of so to say time stamps and I can show
these if I find them on local storage
there you go so I stole them local
storage and they are they give me a
second here and that's how they look
like so this why hopefully it's big
enough is it big enough for the back
yeah good so the why it's just an idea
of the button and two means this one I
think so this one should be one and this
might be zero or maybe this is one this
is two this is three but I'm not quite
sure but why represents the button and I
made this already complicated so x and y
don't mean positions on the screen but
they mean the input sequence this is x
and y is the button that I'm going to
click so this is the input sequence of
mouth positions you see this is position
X this is position Y Delta X Delta Y
that means difference from the previous
mouse position and this is the time step
or delta T so how much time how many
milliseconds past from this event to the
other and sometimes it's very similar
and sometimes it's different so that's
my input and I did some pre-processing
on that because I was considering how
many of them would I really need like
maybe 10 maybe 100 because I didn't know
I cut all these sequences into parts and
trained all of this into the model so
but you could like for example what
would he suggest that you could have
taken anything else and if it works you
find out by experiment that's how it
works in machinery so you make an
assumption you try the model and then
you see if it works and well this might
work at
see so I have the data now and now I
have this this collection of buttons and
I'm the only person in the world right
now who knows how to use this thing
because it's a horrible user interface
giving a talk but user interfaces and
then they playing horribly I apologize
but that's the way it is now I can train
on that data so I collected some data
and I collected some data before you see
I have 369 dataset that means um I don't
know my wave down here from over from
outside to down here I did some clicks
to have some sample data and if you're
at all into machine learning having 370
samples for three categories is nothing
tippity people won't even start they
will say this is not going to work well
but maybe does so I'm clicking this
train model now this is all I've no fall
back that's why I'm having sweaty palms
here so this looks good
reasonably good this is using tensorflow
Jess and tensorflow jess comes with a
very nice brutalization library I did
not write this code so this stuff that
comes with tensorflow Jess and it shows
you something and hopefully something
good
oh and shows me something good but I
didn't know before I kicked off this
thing so it looks good what's most
interesting is these two curves down
here that's why I'm doing it now
and these curves tell you something
about how well the training process
proceeds I will show you some code later
but let's save on the conceptual level
for a while and we concentrate on that
blue curve and the blue curve describes
over time how well is the machine
learning a model able to reproduce the
data that that I gave to it so I've had
in the mouse movement sequences and as a
prediction the button that is going to
be clicked and now the machine learning
tries to learn which sequence spits out
which bar and the higher the blue line
gets the better it is able to do that
and this is around 70
percent or 0.67 that means of the 70
sorry off of all the mouse movements
that I did 70 percent of them the model
is able to predict correctly so I made
some movements to the to the button and
that's pretty good 70 percent on that
pretty astonishing but what's much more
astonishing is the orange line because
that is data points that the model has
never seen that means 20% which I
decided deliberately I've taken off from
the start now it looks good
I've taken off from from the training
data and I'm just using it to constantly
check how well the model is doing on
something it has never seen and is
anyone at all familiar with machine
learning anyone when we say it doesn't
look I mean would it would you have
expected that who would have expected
that maybe you didn't expect that
because I did make myself quite clear
but this is a pretty outstanding result
so it's not something you could expect
from very small training data training
on this machine is a very powerful GPU
but it's still a laptop something like
this typically I don't know it wouldn't
perform that well I'm not quite sure why
does this is so welcome to the world of
machinery you make an experiment you
can't explain it just works and that's
my world at least javascript is also my
world but also that so um before we try
that and I'm hope you saw I just tried
trade this online we can get some more
information and this is also built into
the visualization tools of tensorflow
and I'm always so happy if you guys
don't see any red stuff in the console
because it's it seems to work quite well
and this is a while I'm hiding this for
a second because what you see now it's a
very powerful tool it's called the
confusion matrix I don't think it's only
used in machine learning but in machine
learning it actually is so what can you
see on the y-axis that is this axis here
you see the real buttons that the model
should predict because it knows those
are the real buttons that means left
button middle button right button and on
the x-axis you see the prediction of the
model and this is useful because in the
perfect world and in the model that
works perfectly you would expect all the
clicks to be on that diagonal here but
you don't see that you see something
else so what do you see so this means
the real value that the model should
predict is left and the prediction
actually also is left that's good
but then this here the predictor should
be left but it was middle 22 quite a few
and then the prediction should be left
but it is right and then for all the
three buttons so for the middle button
we see something that at least from my
perspective was expected because the
middle button is so close to the other
buttons that you get a lot of confusion
even though it is the middle button you
get a lot of confusion for either left
or the right button so that's also
totally expected and finally for the
right button that's also something
that's slowly expected and also
something that I would have expected for
the left button so it's actually the
right button but sometimes you confuse
it with the middle button but only
rarely with the left and this is because
of the way I created those silly mouse
movements but it's actually pretty good
even without trying the model I now know
that this model might be good um there
are some problems with it first problem
this is only on the data the model had
we still have no idea is it going to
perform well in real life I mean and
will I do the same mouse movements I
make a little bit interesting because
I'm still I still also don't know but it
could it's it looks good now if you
think you would never show this to the
end user something like this and the end
user would never use something like this
this is totally true and you can at any
time heighten sting and you can toggle
it back in later this is just tools for
developers like me and
I also haven't shown this but while I
was training it was totally usable so
the whole thing was was trained in real
time and the user would not have noticed
that I'm training something I also did
not show him but maybe it's also too
late now the hit on my GPU was immense
and also the the fan of my laptop
started to blow because this takes a lot
of compute power on your GPU uses WebGL
so that means this this is your
installation you could load this in your
browser right now but you wouldn't know
which buttons to click so don't do it
because it has horrible user experience
um so that means the idea is the user
clicks something you record at a certain
point thing this might be enough data
you train the model you get all the
evaluation results and then decide am I
going to use it for a real prediction or
not and this thing might be okay we have
one more metric and this is accuracy per
button that means this is this is just a
number and this number there's an API
for it I'll just question that number
and then I could write some code if the
accuracy is above say 70% for all the
buttons I will enable that model and I
can just do that how shall I do that yes
I'm gonna bit scared I'm really so this
is no show that I'm scared so I can
toggle the prediction and I need to open
the console because all the interesting
stuff is still locked here this is very
early example so now let's see so what
you see I'm doing this thing where I'm
pretty sure that that it will be okay
so just see oh it looks okay so now it
will predict I'm going to click the
right button and there's no explanation
for that yes there might be an intuition
it changes a little bit still right
button but this thing basically is a
black box so you have no idea why does
it you just happy that it does but you
get some information you get some
information down in the console and this
is probability per button so these
so the microphone is here I could have
used the mouse but then I would change
this so let's stick to this one right so
that means the probability for the right
button 75% the probability for the
middle button is 10 and the probability
for the left button is 15% that means at
a certain threshold that I decided to be
50% I will highlight that button and say
the user is going to click that button
and let's see now so middle button you
see I'm not hovering over it I'm them
just close to it left button in works
and I had sweaty hands it sort of works
you wouldn't probably say it's perfect
and it also seems to work on proximity
not not of mouse path right maybe limit
on Mouse path but mostly on proximity at
least that's my impression would you
agree is it Mouse path it's not perfect
you see that it's not perfect but it
might be good enough for anything
reasonable and we just did this on the
fly right here so it's it's not
something that I prepared
um but you might ask it's this maybe you
asked that I don't know if you do I'm
just saying you ask is this the right
way to do or would you rather not use
proximity so much but do you really the
movement of the mouse is that more
interesting and if you value proximity
or the the past of the mouse movement
over a proximity and that is something
that you model into your model and I
will show the model now hopefully sorry
just enough space so um
then it's the tensor flow test part and
all the other part I'm pretty sure all
of you could also write this is just
clicking and then have a mouse missed 9
then have a quick list not all that
stuff and prepare the data has had a
little bit but this is the part where
you only have very few lines of code but
you need to think about those few guys
of course and have variations of this so
this tensorflow thing is it's the
tensorflow namespace I'm saying I want
to a sequential model that means we have
layers they follow each other and the
first and this now it gets interesting
so this stuff before maybe not so much
this says it's a simple RNN and that is
the sort of neural network that can
learn from a sequence of things and
there's a lot of stuff that you don't
need to know about but this will say I
have quite sure how many maybe it's 25
I cut the the mouse movements into into
chunks and then have five features that
means how does the input to this thing
look like and then this says how many
neurons do I want and this is tony
hand-wavy you just try that out and
typically you don't want to use too many
because it needs to be trainable on the
browser and you saw it is if you take
less it goes much faster if you take
more it might not work so well and and
it also takes a lot of time and you saw
the predictions were actually real time
online so the interesting part is the
evaluation of this thing was is much
worse than on the other things that I
will show in a minute but in real life
it showed it showed the behavior that
people actually expected that when I
moved close to a button it should be
highlighted that's the that's a result
people expected but actually maybe you
rather want something where the whole
path the whole movement Falls much
mentor into into account and there are
other styles of neural networks that are
better at this so you decide how much of
the history do you want to keep and how
much interesting how interesting is
their history and I have wait I have
this pre-recorded because I didn't know
if I would be able to make this run in
return so this thing here in the middle
you see it reacts much faster or much
very much earlier it was it was an
earlier version of this thing but it
only reacts not by proximity but of the
path that you did that
mouse describes so it's much more
expensive it took much more resources to
train and it's still not intuitive
because if you if you just move close to
the button it will do won't do anything
because that's not how you click on a
button you don't slow you go to the
button and then you eventually click
this is much more much closer to what
you actually do and if you want to do
that you will use a different type of
machine learning model and this
different type of machine learning model
is commended out here it's called an LS
TM which means long short-term memory
network and you might see that apart
from this thing here where's this it's
same thing and the name is different but
the name is just name of variable then
there's a cheaper version of this which
is called GRU but you could just
exchange that and do different
experiments see and I made some comments
slow to train evaluation is bad but it
actually performed really well and in
its it's the network that I used for the
for the second example good five minutes
left so I will show some more code
unless they're questions right now
questions yes yes so the question is
have I made something like a baseline
where you exit and no but exactly what
you propose also was in my head I'm just
using the vector and I'm seeing what is
the the mouse curve pointing it might be
it works better but I haven't done this
and also not proximity I think it would
be it would be pretty easy to implement
but I didn't want to spoil it for myself
I think maybe it works better if you do
that please contribute it's on github
make a pull request I would be maybe I
would not be so happy but please still
do it could be better so but the point
being here maybe that's maybe the use
case is silly I'm not even sure myself
but the point here is so this data it
never left the browser so this stays in
the browser you can download it yourself
but it will never reach the server of
someone you don't trust in terms of
privacy for example you don't want that
maybe and also the model that you're
training is also completely it stays on
your machine it will not leave your
machine and the prediction will also be
on your machine and it will be in real
time that means you do something and and
the model will predict you didn't see
any at least I didn't see any delay and
you didn't see any installation so you
can start this maybe not on your phone
because you don't have the mouse but you
couldn't start this on any laptop and it
would still work if you know which part
is a click and that's the point so if
you if you have anything you think that
might be a good idea this might be the
right thing otherwise it's pretty hard
to explain why would you even do machine
learning in the browser because for
example the browser doesn't doesn't
train at least in Chrome when when the
the window is not upfront when it's not
high light or when you look at something
else the browser will restrict your
resources so it's not the ideal platform
for training but it might be if you
after previously or high activity so
just well hopefully to show you that
it's not very hard to get this done so
this is something you could copy from
pretty much any tutorial and that's the
whole model so model definition this
part and this part and the other part is
commented out so it doesn't count I
guess and the most experienced that have
put into it
was to make it very general with very
few data sets which is typically
extremely hard and this involves
tweaking with strange parameters where
there's barely any theory to it and one
of the theory sorry one of the
parameters that was tweaking was this
drop out thing and then this patch
normalization and and
this is just experimental you've you
have some intuition and then you just
play with it and you see when it
performs well and what you see as a
result of this very strong well sort of
strong regularization so it still works
with not many data sets sorry
so preparation boring training this is
training so you have the model you call
fit that means you stick in the input
that is the mouse movements and you get
back the button but in this case you
just train the model tell it this is the
true data that I have learned from it
and then there's still too many
parameters that I can't explain now but
I would be able to do that in five
minutes okay then prediction so done
after that this was triggered by one of
the buttons so after that you can
evaluate that somewhere and then
eventually you call predict on that and
this is again model stick in the X data
set get back the Y that means the bar or
in this case to be more accurate the
percentages of probability for each bug
being picked so you can save that to
local storage you can download that and
then you have two files that you can
store you can use the data to train that
on just normal tensorflow which also did
where I exported the data I did the
training and then you can also export
the model that you trained on a real
server and load it into the browser if
you really want to and the idea behind
that is maybe you want to share some
training experience with other people
who are willing to give the data to I
don't know someone else uploaded it to
it to a server and then you could train
the general model upload it to this
thing here I could do this it's loading
remote model now and you can see I don't
know if it's performing well not so much
but also not so bad so this model that I
just loaded it has been trained on a
server probably
more data and still works so with that
I'm closing it and what I would like you
to give to me is is ideas so I don't
with our I don't on person is there
anything any inspiration you got from
this what you could do in the browser
didn't tell me and if I mean if it's
great that you keep it to yourself just
implement and make a lot of money but
maybe maybe if you need I don't know
some going back and forth talk to me I
would be really happy so thank you and
have a nice conference
[Applause]
[Music]